دعوه الى لقاء اخير تلقتها مريم زوجه علي
رضا اكبر من طرف احد المسؤولين الايرانيين
بالحضور لرؤيه زوجها في سجنه بطهران ومع
الدعوه وصل اليقين الى مريم بان زوجها في
طريقه الى الاعدام اكبر اختفى عن الانظار
منذ عام 2019 عاد الى ايران من لندن بدعوه
من امين المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي
الايراني علي شمساني وبحسب عائلتي اكبر
فانا رضا خضع عقب وصوله للتحقيق في مقرات
سريعه مختلفه تابعه لوزاره الاستخبارات
ليتم الاعلان عن اعدامه مرحله داخليه غير
مسبوقه تواجه النظام بشارعا تشعله
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه واقتصاد يكاد ينهار
بالاضافه الى الضغوط الغربيه اعدام علي
رضا اكبر المفاجئ شنقا بعد اربع سنوات من
اعتقاله يحمل بين قاطع وفق خبرراء
محاولاتها تخويف للمحتاجين واشاره
للتصفيات الداخليه في حرب يقودها
المتشددون ورساله للغرب برفض ضغوته اكبر
البريطاني الايراني مزدوجه جنسيه كنا قد
شغل بين عمي
1997 و 2001 منصبه نائب وزير الدفاع
الايراني علي شمخاني في حكومه محمد خاتمي
وبعد مغادرته ايران والسفر الى النمسا
واسبانيا ثم استقراره في بريطانيا بدا
نشاطه الاقتصادي هناك لعشر سنوات اثر
اعتقال اكبري وفي تسجيل صوتيا مسرب نشرته
مواقع اعلاميه اكد انه بريء وان تعذيب
الذي خضع له اجبره على الاعتراف امام
الكاميرا بجرائمه لم يرتكبها فتهمه تجسس
التي دفع اكبر حياته بسببها قال في تسجيله
انها مبنيه على قميص وزجاجه كان قدمهما
هديه لعلي شمخاني متسائلا في تسجيل عن
مصير شمخاني المقبل حنان المصري العربي